six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's go or no caller from
the nine five one area code oh I gave it
how are you good
hey I I moved down to California and and
just got close with the California
wildfires and I was hoping to just talk
a little bit about how we've been
relaxing the standard the building
standards so much in this country that
it's becoming just dangerous to even
hardly live on an upper floor of a
building with the sprinkler systems
weighted reduced and that kind of thing
I ended up coming down to the California
to promote alternative Dovid materials
that are fireproof and I thought that
would might be interesting for someone's
listeners and and that's your job
promoting construction using less
flammable building materials well that's
the business I'm trying to currently
pursue so but I you know we need to look
at building with way more concrete and
steel and things that don't burn
especially in California here that went
from slamming tariffs on it you know
yeah yep that is very tough that when
you know it's being attacked basically
by Trump and but with the wildfires here
I don't think there's any choice that we
have to you know rebuild with non
flammable building materials not just
put something that side in other words
so you're trying to get that business
going but like will you sell the
materials are you looking to do
construction like I'm trying to
understand you looking really consultant
well III planning to build a block
factory out in the desert to build
non-viable building blocks called
air Crete
so that's the besties ultimate goal and
moved out from from Alaska do it so just
trying to get things going you know just
things just keep burning down there so
it's just a you know like to raise
awareness as much as I can about you
know there is alternatives out there
that aren't flammable that we can build
these buildings out of I never have to
have a another paradise that happens
like that the tire count gets wiped out
you know all right very important I
appreciate you making it I'm gonna let
you go it does sound like you're very
busy there and up to a lot of stuff so
you get back to that one of today's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash
back on your purchases it's all
completely free all you have to do is
click the link under this video to get
started and for a limited time everybody
in our audience who signs up gets five
dollars towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below